what's going on guys my name is david
tomic welcome back to the channel
today we're unboxing this bad boy here
the mac
mini m1 don't worry there's nothing
inside it i've already unboxed it it's
all set up ready to go
but let's get on with the unboxing okay
so not only was i fortunate enough to
open
one mac mini but we actually bought two
mac mini and ones
for the office which means i got to
unbox them both
but for today we're only just going to
unbox the one unfortunately there isn't
any nice
tab pulls for the plastic here on the m1
which is a bit odd for apple products
usually they're quite easy to take off
the premium cardboard box is a little
bit tricky to slide off as always
and you want to do it on a table because
it'll just fall off and crash like we
saw that
iphone guy dropped his brand new iphone
on the first day
the mac mini comes wrapped in plastic as
always the little nice pull tabs
oh that sound so nice it comes off very
clean
very quick and feels very very premium
overall very sturdy build a little bit
of black tape here over the back
i'm guessing it's hiding all the ports
it's a little bit harder to peel off
even though i have some nails at the
moment but there we go we're managing to
get most of this black plastic off and
exposing these ports
we have the power port ethernet two
usbcs hdmi
two usb a's a headphone jack and of
course
the fan outlet i'll do some b-roll over
the top of this so you can see that
port layout a little bit better included
in the box we also have some stickers of
course
and the manual just one giant sticker
from apple now
the mac mini little setup instruction
guide which i don't think many of us
need it's all pretty self-explanatory if
you're buying a mac mini you probably
know what you're doing
and also just one power cable that seems
to be
everything in the box the power cable is
extremely fiddly and extremely hard to
get out
but that's okay it comes wrapped pretty
well
and eventually i will get this and
unwrap this whole bloody thing
so the power cable as always is about
i'd say about two meters long it comes
with a standard australian adapter
and the plug so overall
pretty decent size cable you don't
usually need to run them too far
so pretty good um nothing else in the
box
that seems to be it for the unboxing
today guys that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video
and i hope you enjoyed the unboxing if
there's anything you'd like to know
about the mac
m1 mini that is related to architecture
or anything of the product itself
please let me know down in the comments
below if you want to see more content of
this sort make sure you hit that
subscribe button
and as always i will see you very
shortly